Democrats are done for me I know that if
I support you you're telling me all your
whispering sweet nothings into my ear
about the policies you want to enact and
then you're gonna go and scream about
Trump for 20 years and I don't want to
hear it so it's not happening all right
we have Tim Poole mr. Poole are you
there sir
I am indeed can you hear me oh we just
saw someone who looked a little bit like
you there he had your beanie on can you
confirm in fact this is not green-screen
trickery you are not at the White House
I am not actually at the White House but
you know some people try to do what I do
and report write the greatest form of
flattery you know it is also if your
calling card is going to be an item that
can be procured for six dollars at
targets you know it's not necessarily
copyright materials unfortunately for me
cover though it can be looted so there
is that it's free um you just had a
stream going on right Tim Poole I did
yes and what were you guys talking about
the stream we've been watching CNN and
it's been remarkable that they have been
trying to avoid going to the ground
tonight yeah at all costs they're not
showing the ground the one time they cut
to the ground we heard what sounded like
mortars going off the police
respectfully asking folks to honor the
perimeter they said no and then we
hadn't gone back until just now so what
have you guys been covering Minneapolis
is talking about disbanding their Police
Department and what city funding of
police yeah totally disbanding it Wow
yeah so that's where we're at and we
just had some conversations about what
would that would mean I mean it sounds
crazy but there's actually some
arguments for why it might work if you
consider what black lives matter
activists have been talking about this
guy Hank Newsom is having armed
community patrols so they're responsible
for their own community and their own
policing there's an argument for it a
conversation to be had I'm not saying
it's perfect but I was thinking about it
I'm like all the two-way people would
probably probably probably be happy to
see all of these liberals now defending
the right to bear arms yes that's
interesting responsibility for their own
safety and stop putting the
responsibility on police to come and
rescue them when you know crime is
happening right but they don't work that
but they don't want to defend the Second
Amendment they really just wanted to go
to a federal level where they can indict
people who disagree with them that's the
problem they literally want gu
the crazy ones well I don't know I mean
as Rasheeda Talib suggested that hey we
expand the second amendment cuz this is
you know right yeah the most vocal
legislator that I know in other words if
someone said hey defund the police and
let's have a robust defense of the
Second Amendment I would listen to them
I've only heard defund the police from
people who also say strip the Second
Amendment am I am I mistaken because I
want to be corrected
mostly corrects mostly correct okay it's
just Hank Newsom he's a black lives
matter leader I think based out of New
York who said we need to arm ourselves
and be responsible for our communities
and that solves the problem it's an
interesting argument yeah Minneapolis
isn't saying that they're saying we're
discussing disbanding the police because
irredeemably broken and they don't know
what the alternative is right so maybe
start with with with a transition or
I'll turn it up before you talk about
just getting rid of the police is right
it's you know ultimately what we talked
about is maybe the city living has
become untenable it's just you've got
too many problems right you can't afford
it smells like sour milk maybe it's time
to move out of these cities that's very
very generous when I walk through New
York City
I smell human you know just see humans
taking this Tompkins Square Park not a
joke took us and then he reached into
his pocket I swear to you this is true
no he took reach into his pocket took
out there was a syringe in his finger
and rather than using his other hand to
pull it out he just went like this like
it was so casual yeah reaches in so
practice and dirty syringes so he took a
[ __ ] pulled up his pants Reese into his
pocket and there's a syringe like like
it was a fly that was in the san
francisco tourist ad right there's your
Sanford wait his Tompkins Square Park
San Francisco no excuse me what was that
Tim Poole
that's New York isn't it yeah that's
what I was thinking but an audio Wade
stepped on me geez I wasn't listening he
makes a horrible fat lady singing
something else too I want to know for
people who don't if you're very confused
cultural appropriation months you're
doing Norway today Tim Poole we talked
about this earlier today
you and I off air so you obviously are
more of a moderate and you have never
owned a firearm before correct nope
never now it seems like your opinion has
changed and that you and welcome Tim
pulls audience explained to me when your
flash of genius was when that moment was
that you wanted to get a firearm it
wasn't it wasn't a flash of genius it
was a couple years ago I was still very
much like I was I respect people's right
to own firearms but I think there's some
reasonable arguments for control
measures and then someone messaged me on
my youtube channel saying if we can have
reasonable controls and Second Amendment
then I want controls on your First
Amendment and I immediately was like
that's actually a really great argument
I concede so while I think you know
there have been issues I concede
probably ready at there like with his
beer and he had his fate but he's like
alright I'm going to employ your right
police perimeter yeah okay so that's a
point it's logic it's it's me saying you
know honestly I haven't had real
sit-down conversations with people who
were talking about how this functions
and there was a gap in my sight but I
still didn't buy one when covitz started
escalating actually no I'm sorry I'm
sorry I gotta walk this back it was when
the pedophile showed up to my house at
4:00 in the morning and tried breaking
in when the police instructed me to go
buy a gun right in in a manner of
speaking they said if it were me I'd
open the door with a shotgun so I tried
going through the house yeah yeah good
cops yeah it dude it's it's it's tough
it's tough in New Jersey to get a gun
well that's what we were talking about
so let you know because listen you're in
New Jersey and obviously you know
Manhattan itself was like a war zone for
several days and some of the protests
have been peaceful where it's only a
couple hundred people in you know in
smaller areas where they march but
obviously New Jersey can turn on a dime
so you were telling me it's hard to buy
a gun that can you tell me exactly what
it what it is first off there are no
firearms to find right now they're
picked clean right but what the process
would be like there for example like for
a handgun
so the first thing I did was I called
some administration I can't remember
they said go to the police department I
go to the police department they gave me
conflicting instructions told me to fill
out a form then go online the website
didn't exist Wow I'm not kidding it's
like the DMV with boat with exit wounds
yeah yep so what they told me I would
have to fill out and like like write an
essay I'm not kidding they said I have
to write an essay explaining why I need
one but I'm not kidding is it totally
serious
oh my so at that point I was just like
this is not I gotta move out of the
state or something because they've given
me no clear instructions they couldn't
tell me what I was supposed to do where
I was supposed to go so more recently
with kovat and everyone rushing to the
stores I started looking into it again
but didn't get serious until the
full-blown riots nationwide and that's
when I was like I'm gonna actually spend
the time and do the hard digging and I
found some path towards getting away
getting a gun in New Jersey right that
had me fill out a form with a bunch of
numbers I didn't know if they meant it
told me to find complete case compliant
numbers which weren't included in
anything no instructions at all right
and I really do believe they try to make
it as hard as possible for a regular
person who has never bothered gun before
to go through the hoops of actually
buying one yeah right finally I got to
the point where I could fill out the
federal ID or whatever went and dealt
with fingerprinting and things like that
and it's any my dream this it was during
this in-between period that you were
raped correct
via a very large evil monster came out
of my closet
yes John lemon so a couple first off a
couple of things because I understand I
know that you have you have some some
compound bows if I'm not mistaken right
that's kind of what you're using right
now I got a bunch or compound bows for
recurves to Hungarian traditionals
is robbing and this is this is more
because it's fun you know we weren't
thinking that we were gonna be like
ninja warriors with bows or whatever no
no we're we're actually like we want to
go range shooting
and have a good time yeah sure just have
fun no I actually wanna we want to get
guns for security yeah no sticking a
broad head in a looter can be a good
time fun for the whole family well let
me explain some of you so we talked
about this earlier today I want everyone
to know full disclosure I talked about
it with with Tim and my heart went out
to him because I come from a place in
Canada where you can't protect your
stuff it's rely on the government and
then well we're gonna disband the police
force so first off a big thanks to
obviously our sponsor Walter but they
specialize in handguns and I want to
thank sig sauer who they're actually
sending us since we can't find any here
a whole lot of sig 365 V crammed there
jacketed hollow points if we only have
some range ammo and even then writes a
nine-millimeter and here's the things
been out for a while we obviously wanted
to send our sponsor Walter but I don't
even know if they have anything
compliant with New Jersey and handguns
are a lot harder to get in New Jersey
long guns are a little bit different so
we will be sending you now courtesy of
sig I have to say this legally but we
will be the one sending you actually a
brand new Sig Sauer M 400 thread it's a
sporting semi-auto rifle in the ar-15
family or platform again it's from me
compliments of sig because we told them
about your scenario they're actually
going to we're going to send it directly
to your FFL and they will immediately
make the adjustments needed to make it
New Jersey compliant which typically
means sure but you getting it is better
than than nothing and when we're done
with this hit we'll probably talk
tomorrow and will expedite that to you
because I know how hard it is thanks man
seriously yeah I white fire but you can
use it I mean that's that's cool no
actually I'm kind of mad cuz I want one
of these yeah yeah let me can I use it
[Laughter]
you allowed to come in New Jersey I
don't know if I'm allowed to come in New
Jersey I'm gonna get a serious ass
whoopin and here's one thing I want to
show you I don't know if I can Tim C
programmer just sees me he sees you he
sees me so right now again Don Lemon is
showing two black guys from the Floyd
family at Ricky showed attorneys from
the Floyd family but a friend from Floyd
and now they're showing attorneys right
here for the Floyd family they are not
going to the ground which is remarkable
to me I
if you've been following this and
something else did were you aware of you
know we just had register bandit bring
this up were you I'm sure you were aware
of Donald Trump posting that very
heartfelt tribute to George Floyd where
he called for unity where he said we
need more hugs and fewer clenched fists
and that was removed from Twitter for
copyright they still have information up
there by the way that's false about the
NYPD unloading on a 19 year old boy
unarmed it was actually a
thirtysomething year-old who was I
believe shooting at the cops
so no fat check on that but they removed
Donald Trump's video and then CNN Don
Lemon just said and Donald Trump
couldn't take a minute out of his day to
honor George Floyd yeah have you been
following it and are you aware of that
copyright video that was taken down from
Trump no I'm hearing about it just now I
knew it I know he put it up but yeah the
things Twitter is doing you know if you
search racist on Twitter Donald Trump is
the first thing that pops up really Wow
yes Wow it's dude the things I've been
seeing in the news and on social media
are getting freaky
I don't think it was bad last year well
you see what you would have on the New
York Times they're having an internal
revolt their staff won an opinion piece
from Tom cotton removed because he was
supporting Trump's call for military
action oh yeah New York Times is bending
over backwards for these people right
now to be clear to people just calling
it the New York Times are bending over
for people who are not Don Lemon not
well yeah it wouldn't be but yeah that
so you weren't aware that was taken down
and let me ask this do you think as
someone who specializes in this you know
you look at that sort of trail I think I
told you someone attempted to DOX us
posted the wrong address so I just but I
don't want anyone to be nobody yeah
six times it took over 30 hours for
Twitter to get to it but right away when
I tweeted out today if you kneel before
a mob you're a party that was reviewed
and to Twitter Twitter's credit wasn't
removed but that was reviewed within
minutes daxing isn't quite on their
priority let me know Twitter sent a
message because of CO vid we're
backlogged so let me ask you do you
think that there is like triangulation
almost like picture you know
velociraptors in Jurassic Park two in
the corn do you think that was a
concerted effort where they go okay
we're not going to fact check this
verifiably false information on the NYPD
we're going to remove Donald Trump's
video on a copyright bogus claim even
though other videos that have way more
just copyright violations are still
allowed and then the media works with
them and says oh now we can go out there
and say that Donald Trump hasn't
commented on it do you think it's just
all happenstance that they don't have
researchers or do they have a direct
line of communication because that those
three things change the if people watch
CNN would change the entire public
perception of reality well what we can't
say definitively Twitter has admitted
there are only basically fact-checking
Trump and some conservatives their
official response was we don't intend to
correct every bit of misinformation that
being so the response to this was that
you know Joe Biden Hillary Clinton
Schumer I've put out false information
that is gone completely ignored and then
when Trump gets flagged Twitter's
responses well we don't flag everything
so it's just a process by the way that
felonious Floyd you see his name they
say felonious Aloni is its fellow no say
I think Floyd but it's just it's just a
weird coincidence
I knew someone who was once named Ginola
RIA really well I don't think that's
true I think it is that person so let me
let me ask this Tim what is it that you
think is the most dangerous I guess
right now in this coverage my biggest
concern and I talked about this early on
is and now I have the Nicolas Cage Tim
are you excited about your ar-15 my
biggest concern is and how old are you
mr. Poole
they're 34 okay so you're two olders
you're two years older than me but one
year younger than brian Stelter that's
true no wait you're a year older than
brian Stelter brian Stelter is our age
Tim Poole oh he's gonna be around a
while and this is new and improved brian
Stelter with my worry is having been
raised in a post-racial world Canada
post-racial America that when you have
the media saying this is because of race
it's black black black black black lives
matter platon people are watching and
they're going my cities destroyed and by
the way I want to be very clear there
are black officers and there are white
looters but the media is saying black
black black black black my worry is that
you have an entire generation of people
more racist
because they go why is my town destroyed
and they flip on the TV and go black
that being said that's my biggest
concern
what's your biggest concern with the
coverage of all this which is I think we
would all agree is worse than it's ever
been in our life shocking
yeah no I agree with you so one of the
things that's been mind-numbing for me
and it's become a meme where I mentioned
that I'm I come from a mixed-race family
is that I'm in the worst position
between these two groups because I
either bend the knee I have I have no
privilege amongst them because they say
I'm white right if I disagree then they
everything I say is wrong if I so my
only choice is to agree with them
otherwise I'm the other but I literally
don't even have the privilege of being
white literally like to how they
describe it because my family does it
the way the way I'm trying to put it is
their ideology puts me in the most
awkward position where I have no racial
identity like they do right these weird
white liberals talk about their
experiences in the suburbs I'm from the
south side of Chicago but then because
the way they perceive me they I don't
get the benefits of their ideology just
the detriment right so I I'm basically
trying to agree with you say no you're
screwed I know that he's not because he
is half Korean oh let's play that let's
play that audio hos like you can pull a
little bit of this you can pull that and
be a roof top career as a clip with your
m400 shred courtesy of us but thank you
sake for helping us apply it let me let
me let me reiterate this in a better way
I have been I have interviewed white
supremacists you know nationalists and
they have disdain for me and my family
and they say they say awful things yeah
I don't care though it rolls off my back
if the left wins your listen Korean back
here in that Steve King look Steve King
gets loses his primary because he said
things that Americans didn't want to
hear right if things that were
considered either white nationalist or
racist the left is emboldened by their
racists and these weird things that
freaked out me and my family so my hope
is that American as the identity
survives and that's what wins because
that's the only thing I have where's
there's no right there's no outcome yeah
with these right with these weird
identitarian on the left or the
right where I win and my family wins
right if people in my position are going
to do better it's gonna be Americans
recognizing they're just American first
and foremost but if we end up with white
identity Rena's I'm screwed and if we
end up with 11 into terian ISM I'm
screwed so I'd rather just we all be
Americans and agree on our civil rights
I agree I think that's very well said
let me ask you this because I know that
you said in the past you know you were
moderate I think you voted for Obama
correct the first time the first time
and the second time did you not vote or
did you vote not vote okay Romney's
pretty tough if your mom's difficult the
Mormon who puts his dog on his roof I
think he's wrong politically it's a
tough sell but let me ask you say it's
fair you've said before like obviously
you you're not necessarily a big fan of
Donald Trump but do you now take into
account after these riots that have vote
for anyone other than Donald Trump
is a vote for someone who wants you to
have only a double-barreled shotgun or
revolver with more extensive paperwork
than you're talking about now there's no
two ways about it yes yeah yeah so I do
I did this show the Tim cast IRL show
with my buddy Adam and Lydia Adam is a
skateboarding hippie liberal guy rip
Chicago lives in New York and he just
comes out and he's like after seeing all
this I'm voting for Trump and I was like
whoa Wow Wow
I I was talking to someone recently
someone I've known for a really really
long time
diehard Democrat as long as I've known
them messaging me saying the only way
this ends is if Trump wins re-election
and the Republicans take all you know
the house in the Senate and I was like
whoa Wow for Eli and you know I was
talking to a local in my area contractor
and I was asking him how they felt about
all this they said to me they don't care
for politics it was this guy who's in
his mid-20s
did a construction work and he said you
know honestly man I don't know anything
about this stuff but I'm gonna vote for
Trump because I'm sick and tired of the
attacks I just don't understand why
they're always yelling and complaining
so I'm just gonna vote for this guy now
well this was so mates tell me he didn't
vote for Trump the first time he is now
I combined these things with everything
I see with what's going out Biden
falling asleep and just being out of his
mind
yeah the progressives ragging in the
Democrats and I can't envision a future
where trouble
so right and by the way he said he did
say diehard Democrats was the worst a
sequel of the diehards I was playing
taking a knee saying never Paul let me
ask you Tim not to put in you don't if
you believe in a secret ballot has this
changed do you think that where you are
now would you cast a vote and has it
changed
I'm not definitively confirmed for Trump
but I have stated leaning in that
direction all right and there's reasons
for this so Democrats are done for me I
I donated to them recently yang Tulsi
but with with what they've done with him
impeachment with what they did with
rigging the DNC with how they shut out
the candidates that I wanted to hear
from I just said you know what man these
moderate Democrats in Congress ran on
kitchen table issues and then as soon as
they were given the one ring they
laughed and went right for impeachment
yeah and that's that's not worth
supporting right but I still get text
messages from these people and I said
listen man I know that if I support you
you're telling me all your whispering
sweet nothings into my ear about the
policies you want to enact and then
you're gonna go and scream about Trump
for 20 years and I don't want to hear it
so it's not happening when it comes to
the president I'll tell you what scared
me is Joe Biden they lost their minds
yes they have their minds and he kneeled
he kneeled which tomato's melt that is
so well is it is Nelson idler leave it's
melt man these beers are strong can L
talk well a couple of things there you
know Andrew yang I'm sure you saw his
tweets where he was encouraging like
insurrection has that changed your
opinion I know he does oh yeah kind of a
dick move
I have to tell you I know you're kind of
obviously I appreciate your journalistic
integrity but if you don't vote for
Trump you don't get your signature post
it on Twitter the picture of an illegal
picture of you in the voting booth yeah
all right Tim well Tim we've you have to
get going where's the best place for
people to find you and watch your new
show youtube.com slash Tim cast IRL on
Twitter at Tim casts I mean honestly if
you search YouTube for Twitter I have
like three or four channels all under
the same thing oh you're still showing
up in search well that's cute
the sig sauer M 400 thread and like we
said we couldn't send you a handgun so
uh at this point Walter has been a
wonderful sponsor to the show yeah but
it's more important that people are able
to protect themselves if they don't sell
any rifles and I've had great experience
with with I've always said this it's
like BMW Mercedes at a certain point
yeah they're all very good once you get
beyond you know the Saturday night
specials okay I know Taurus yeah so we
wouldn't do that because I don't I don't
want you to actually be raped that
wouldn't send you a Taurus yeah that's
right m400 you need a you know you'll be
in touch with us and there do need to be
some modifications there in New Jersey
for us to send it out but thank you so
much brother
stay safe I appreciate it thanks for
making the time likewise if you like
this video click one of these other
videos playing in a box up there and hit
subscribe or the notification bell if
you're already subscribed so you can
find out about our new non-controversial
videos which don't ruffle any feathers
and of course are not a violation of
YouTube's algorithms everyone's welcome
here except oh I don't know if we are
but it's our channel not sure how that
works